dónde está este punto en la recta
numérica tenemos aquí una recta numérica
inicia en 1.5 o lo que es lo mismo 1 y 5
décimas y llega hasta 1 y 7 décimas la
distancia entre cada una de estas marcas
azules es una décima por qué avanzas de
uno y cinco décimas a uno y seis décimas
es decir avanza una décima y después de
uno y seis décimas avanza otra décima
para llegar a uno y siete décimas por lo
tanto esta distancia es una décima una
décima
como decimal se escribe 0.1 y como
fracción 1 sobre 10
eso es una décima esta distancia también
es una décima
ahora nosotros queremos saber dónde está
este punto verde es decir qué número
representa y para averiguarlo
necesitamos conocer cuánto mide cada una
de estas pequeñas distancias
entonces de aquí aquí es una décima y
dentro de esa décima hay uno dos tres
cuatro cinco seis siete ocho nueve diez
espacios iguales entonces cada uno de
estos espacios iguales es una décima
parte de esta distancia porque
representa una de las diez partes
iguales entonces eso es una décima parte
de esta décima ahora observa esta
distancia grande es una décima y esto es
una décima de esa décima a otra manera
de decirlo es esto es una centésima una
décima de una décima es una centésima es
decir estás dividiendo una décima en
diez partes iguales y así es como
obtienes una centésima
entonces esta distancia es una centésima
lo cual significa que cada una de estas
distancias pequeñas también representan
una centésima
esta es una centésima esa es otra
centésima entonces cuántas centésimas
tenemos que avanzar para llegar de uno y
cinco décimas al punto verde veamos aquí
tenemos una centésima dos centésimas
tres cuatro cinco seis siete centésimas
siete centésimas fue lo que tuvimos que
avanzar para llegar al punto verde ahora
como fracción se escribe siete sobre
cien
eso es siete centésimas como decimal
0.07 con el siete situado en el lugar de
las centésimas
ahora viéndolo como un todo iniciamos en
1.5 o lo que es lo mismo 1 y 5 décimas y
avanzamos 7 centésimas entonces 1.5 +
0.07 es decir 1 y 5 décimas más 7
centésimas eso da un total de 1 y 57
centésimas o 1.57 por lo tanto el punto
verde está situado en 1 punto 57 1 y 5
décimas más 7 centésimas nos lleva a 1 y
57 centésimas